right as we've been explaining the
media's proven they will stoop to new
lows as Waldo was just described
describing to destroy and of course D
legitimize Donald Trump's presidency and
the stormy Daniels hysteria is the
latest example here to weigh in on all
of this he is the host of C our TVs
Levin TV the host of life liberty Levin
the great one I call him right here on
the Fox News Channel Sunday nights 10:00
p.m. the number one show on his timeslot
thank me oh I'm look this is too serious
I'm watching Anderson Cooper we did a
side-by-side yeah
Jerry Springer Cooper because he asked
the same questions that Jerry Springer
ass and they've done this 24/7 for weeks
the same network that never interviewed
Juanita Broderick till October and 2016
mark this is not tabloid this is a
gender driven sucker driven drivel
because he has an agenda against Donald
Trump well and they're getting ratings
you see what 60 minutes did they had the
greatest ratings they say that doesn't
have those uh yeah exactly but the truth
is if Donald Trump's last name was
Kennedy we'd not be seeing a thing of
this they'd be covering it up and here's
the difference number one why is it
assumed that the porno actress and the
ex Playboy bunny are telling the truth
and why are the media focused on this
let's take a look at Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton was accused of sexual assault in
the Oval Office Bill Clinton was accused
of having sex with an intern in the Oval
Office Bill Clinton was accused as
Attorney General an official position of
raping Juanita Broderick Bill Clinton
was attorney was governor of Arkansas
accused of using his position to try and
get sex and exposing himself to an
employee Paula Jones Donald Trump isn't
even close even if you believe all this
which I know he's not even close to this
stuff John Kennedy had an affair with a
mob boss's girlfriend job John Kennedy
had a relationship with an East German
spy John Kennedy had sex with an intern
in the White House
poor John can I mean so many example LBJ
was said to be worse than John Kennedy I
can go on and on and on now the media
will say well that's a diversion no I'll
tell you what's a diversion the media
have ignored the rogue activity of the
highest levels of the FBI the media have
ignored Russia's influence in our
election we now know that the Obama
administration knew about it that Susan
Rice knew about it told the people to
stand down we got these lectures from
Mark Warner and Adam Schiff
unbelievable they said the Russians
would get involved in our election there
right now that we know that the Obama
administration knew about it vertically
horizontally departments and agencies
and did nothing about it
moreover we know that lies were told to
a federal judges at the FISA Court to
get a warrant to spy on an American
citizen and then for a year they got
three extensions the media do not care
about that so what do the media care
about the fortification of the media
last week it was Donald Trump was
mentally ill so they dragged this
professor out from Yale and prancin her
from one station to another before that
it was this kook with his book Michael
Wolfe everybody didn't trust them but
anyway he was good for a week and then
we got to hear from this idiot for a
week and it goes on and on and on the
media obviously hey Trump here's what
they're trying to do they know that
Trump supporters aren't going to be
persuaded by any of this well what
they're trying to do is get two people
out there who don't really pay a lot of
attention who may not be Trump
supporters and to keep driving the stake
and driving the stake and grabbing
anything they can including a porno star
who I'd never heard of any of these
people before and all of a sudden
they're presented to the American people
as if they're truth tellers this
Anderson Cooper you know I didn't watch
this you showed this on your show
earlier the questions he was asking has
he no shame is he not embarrassed the
children of this country to listen to a
reporter you know living on about the
kind of Sex Lies Lena sex when you had
sex it's creep what is it it's sick
it's a news story I think so these
reporters are enjoying
their computers doing research on
Daniels or whatever name is smokey
Daniels whatever Dorman stormy stormy
Daniels and smokey stormy know the
difference they're starting starting to
get a kick anyway that's really pathetic
I'm actually crying